-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with J.B. Smoove.
Alright, we heard Pizza Table.
Do you have
another "Shark Tank" for us?
-Of course I do.
This is amazing.
This is going to
revolutionize relationships.
It's called What I Say?
It's an app, right?
It's an app.
So, when you're in an argument,
the main thing about
an argument is this.
"You didn't say that.
You didn't say that."
"Yes, I did. Yes, I did."
So, it's called What I Say?
And it rewinds your life
or this moment, right?
It records the last minute or
two of the conversation.
So you can always go back.
It works the same way as
your security cameras
in your home.
It just naturally stays on and
records the argument.
And it has a unique sensor
that senses
an argument about to happen,
and it comes on automatically.
And you program your app
to a certain volume
so that if she's yelling
from the room,
you got to set it
from where it's at.
And then can you go back.
"I didn't say that."
"Yes, you did."
And you hit the button
on the app,
and it will play back
what the hell you just said.
See? It's called What I Say?
What I Say?
What did I say?
How did this happen?
Why are we arguing right now?
What happened?
What did I say?!
-It's really good, J.B.
-Isn't that great?
-I want to congratulate you
on the fact
that you're Emmy-nominated for
"Mapleworth Murders."
You're -- One of your
fellow nominees
is the co-creator of the show,
our old friend John Lutz.
But there's also some --
You know, not that
you guys aren't heavy hitters,
but you're also in the category
with Kevin Hart, John Travolta.
Pretty good list.
-Mm-hmm.
It's a good list, Seth.
And here's what I'm saying.
I think John and I -- One of us
has a great chance to win this.
-When you say "John,"
do you mean Lutz or Travolta?
-John Lutz.
John Lutz and I, I feel,
have a great, great chance
to win this.
You know, people love --
People love John Travolta.
You know?
And I'm just worried
that they may --
You know how
they give people awards
for something
they previously did?
I just don't want it to happen.
I don't want them
to give him this Emmy
for this show he did based on
"Saturday Night Fever."
I don't want this to happen.
I just don't want
this to happen.
It happens all the time.
-Yeah.
-You know, it happens.
They give you an award for
something you did previously,
and I don't want that to happen.
I don't want that to happen.
Or he gets that Sweathog
sympathy, you know,
from being a damn Sweathog.
I don't want that either.
-No. I mean, come on.
To the vo-- If any voters
are watching, please,
save us your Sweathog sympathy.
Now, I will say --
-Don't do that.
-J.B., J.B.,
would you be honest?
Would you be honest --
Be honest with me.
Would you be okay if people
gave you some Leon love?
Like, if they're like, "Oh, I
loved him as Leon on 'Curb,'
so I'm going to vote for him,"
do -- Will you accept that vote?
-I'll be disappointed.
You know, I've been on that
damn show six seasons.
Five, six seasons now.
I don't need no sympathy award.
I wouldn't --
You know what I would do?
I would give it to John.
I would give it to John
if I won it.
It's John's.
Take it! Take it!
I don't want that sympathy.
But here's what I recommend.
If John should win, here's what
I think we should do.
We're a team on the same show.
Here's what I think
we should do.
We should make this Emmy
like the Stanley Cup.
See? We share it
and we both have it
for a certain amount of time
and we go on tour with it
and we raise it above our head
and go places with it.
Because, you know, we won this.
It's the same damn show.
We're on the same damn show.
-Now, this show
was originally on Quibi,
and now you can
watch it on Roku.
Did you have Roku before
"Mapleworth" went to Roku?
-No, I did not have it.
Now, all these weird names
throw me off a little bit.
Quibi sounds like a small,
little town in Canada somewhere.
Doesn't it? It has a ring to it.
Like, "I'm going over to Quibi
for the weekend."
You know what I mean?
And Roku sound like one of
those delicious sushi rolls
at one of those places,
you know?
Doesn't it sound like that?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Or a hot pepper.
Like, it's 10 times as hot
as a jalapeño.
Like, the Roku pepper
or something like that.
Doesn't it sound --
It reminds me of something
you're not supposed to eat,
but, somehow,
somebody made it cool.
You know what I'm saying?
It's, like, undigestible,
so it goes in and comes out
the same way.
You know what I'm saying?
You can't even chew it.
You got to swallow it,
like a pill, you know?
That's the Roku pepper.
-Well, I definitely think,
when they named the app,
they were hoping people
would come to this conclusion.
-You know what?
I think they would.
-Yeah.
-I think they should.
-Anything that has
J.B. Smoove is
10 times hotter than a jalapeño.
Let me tell you that much.
-Whoo!
See? You know me so well,
because, normally --
I'mma tell you something
about you.
A lot of times, you know,
I feel like you debunk.
You are a debunker.
-I'm a debunker?
-You're a debunker.
You know what a debunker is?
You debunk some things that
I say sometimes
like you don't believe
exactly what I'm saying.
-J.B., I'm going to let you go,
because we all want you to
finish that drink.
-Oh, it's delicious.
Hey, you should -- When you hold
a drink in your hand,
it makes people comfortable.
You should do
that on your show, Seth.
You should have
a little cocktail
in your hand and always do this.
"Now, you people know
out there..."
You know, and then do
your whole monologue
with a drink in your hand,
you know?
Some people say a drink
in your hand
and one hand down the front of
your pants like Al Bundy,
but I think that's too far.
I think that's too much.
[ Laughter ]
-"Mapleworth Murders"
is streaming now on
The Roku Channel.